[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the pc gaming
show 2022 i'm day nine still one of your
hosts joined again by the amazing mika
berger
while we may look like elaborate unreal
engine renders we are here in the flesh
as is the hardware bringing you the best
and brightest in the world of pc gaming
over the next two hours we are going to
showcase a metric ton of killer upcoming
pc games through world premieres
exclusive interviews and a few surprises
along the way and you the folks at home
might even be able to win yourself a
fancy computer if you play your cards
right and now you may remember the last
time you saw me on this show things
ended quite literally explosively yeah
yeah there was a robot who tried to
destroy the human race electrocuted me i
i think i died definitely died either
way i'm not really sure it was standard
robot apocalyptic stuff just minus the
overbearing anime dad of existential
crises yeah well actually what happened
to devbot anyway wasn't he supposed to
come back for this show like revenge of
the devbot
well he's dead oh we melted him down to
try to make our own graphics card since
they're still hard to find and i would
say he's in a better place but i played
cyberpunk 2077 and he's not
that's pretty dark for a starter show or
nostalgic
but none of that matters because the
show actually took place in a parallel
reality all right so you're telling me
there's actually a multiverse according
to the writers who told me this five
minutes before we went live i am saying
there's a multiverse all right we're now
apparently on earth 3.
not to be confused with e3 because this
show is still happening
and we are so thrilled to be back as a
part of this weekend full of
celebrations of gaming by putting the
spotlight on something near and dear to
our hearts pc gaming and so without any
further ado it's time for my favorite
part
rated and premature
in the beginning
the world was subjugated by chaos
endless droves of horrors trespassed
into the world
between death and transcendence a
chimera chooses death
show us what you thought
may the judge have mercy on your souls
[Music]
you are here with me
i always will be
as long as we are together
we're not going down
yet another monster
they shall have
one must resist it
so
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just saw tactical breach wizards a
turn-based game of sorcery and swat team
strategy from the makers of gunpoint and
heat signature my strategy personally is
very simple breach bang clear magic
missile dramatic flourish abra cadaver
get it cadabra dead body
next we have a solution to the age-old
problem of not having time to read and
play video games just do both at the
same time obviously star wars industries
has you covered with their sci-fi
thriller inspired by stanislaw's novel
the invincible so here's your first look
at the first ever gameplay footage
[Music]
you
what have you done
[Music]
where are you taking me
you came here yourself so what are you
expecting huh
you've set up a field camp down there
yeah so i didn't expect you to have a
second one here sit here
what are you doing here you're not gonna
like this part
the radiation level is growing rapidly
it's starting to get interesting
i'll pretend i didn't hear that doctor
[Applause]
ugh
i located the mobile antimatter cannon
another one
how many of those today is it active
dead
i admire your composure
wait someone's here
they're dead
so you found someone
unfortunately such unpleasant
discoveries are indispensable to the
mission
i didn't let that thought get to me i
was counting on this meeting very much
it was
it could have been another abandoned
place but not this
but what exactly
that's a good question
i'm getting into the recorder
what do we have
here
uh-huh
they made their way through
with a beam of antimatter
how subtle
did you locate this passage
[Music]
on looking at it now they pierced a hole
several meters in diameter and several
dozen meters long
[Music]
yes
my head feels like it's bursting from
pressure
can you continue
yes
i'm better now
actually there's nothing here that i
haven't seen before there are a lot of
metal bushes that were near a camp
the lower parts of the bushes are
how to put it
fruitless
so they came to pick the fruits
this robot looks like it has started his
task and got stuck
what task
this is one of the robots carrying
containers with research material it
took the container but never left that
place
why do you think it's stuck
well it goes in circles using the same
path
the robot's gone
you must have broken his loop but i
didn't i must have done something it
never might follow it
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's getting up what a robot
no antimatter
yes it's [ __ ] up the
robot what's it doing now
[Music]
take care of our people novik
it's time to take a pit stop at the
nearest dungeon to prove that chivalry
isn't dead and if you think i emphasize
those words weirdly you're right and
it'll all make sense momentarily when
you see these next four games especially
when you hear from our friends at
tripwire interactive roll that beautiful
footage
you nah
you don't have what it takes
you'll be back here too scared to try
again
because the dungeon will turn you into
lunch me
unless you're way tougher than you look
we got the guns
the turrets
the upgrades
but what you really need
is guts and
grab your skills and say your prayers
[Music]
be the first to play
to die
to give your feedback
do you have what it takes
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to f1 manager 2022 the ultimate
f1 simulation putting you in the
position of team principal at one of the
10 current f1 teams battling it out for
a chance to be the next world champion
choose your team and drive every
decision that leads to you making your
mark on the grid and hopefully the
podium
winning championships depends on your
ability to make the right calls on and
off the track
during race is your mastermind strategy
plan tire stints for each driver and
make changes on the fly when necessary
issue driver call-outs such as
instructing them to attack or defend
manage their tyre wear and battery usage
or even to avoid battling a teammate
all while reacting to dynamic events
like race incidents and fluctuating
weather and track conditions
between race weekends you'll control
every detail of your team from your
state-of-the-art headquarters
hire best in class staff to work across
your aerodynamics and engineering teams
and put them to the task to develop your
car and prepare new parts for upcoming
races
optimize your finances to keep the board
happy improve and maintain your
facilities and scout talent from f2 and
f3 to try and ensure future success
they say knowledge is power and keeping
a close eye on a plethora of realistic
data will help give you the edge
from the finer details of how car parts
affect overall performance to attracts
expected grip level to the condition of
your wind tunnel
how you analyze the data and choose to
spend your resources will make or break
your progress
you'll find depth and detail and
abundance even down to real-world team
radio messages between drivers and
engineers and race commentary from david
croft and karoon chandok while broadcast
style presentation showcases 2022's
striking new car design with real
trackside and on-board camera angles
the sleek management menus and intuitive
controls will drive the immersive f1
fantasy home as you plan and execute the
perfect strategy in f1 manager 2022
pre-order the digital version now for
early access from august 25th
hey everyone after one year of chivalry
2 we've more than doubled the size of
the game and now we're excited to bring
even more knights onto the battlefield
because today right now chivalry 2 is
out on steam with cross play between all
platforms this is our biggest update to
the game yet and it brings players to an
all new desert theater of war and best
of all brings us horses into chivalry 2
in mounted combat we want to thank our
community for making the game the
success that it's been so far and if you
haven't played it yet now is the best
time to check out chivalry 2 take a look
at our new trailer that shows off the
new update in its notion invasion
[Applause]
this rebellion is at an end
the agapians lead to their stronghold in
the north
this land
[Music]
dogs back into the desert
their pulses will crash and break
against the bulwark
if the wall falls
we must retaliate
ready the ships
long has senosia remain safe from my
fury
no more
[Music]
they dare to strike out of us
their cities
will fall
their people
will bleed
their knowledge will burn
my reign
will never end
hi everyone i'm phil from sweet bandits
live from quebec city really glad to be
here today for the pc gaming show we'll
be showing the first trailer for our
game this eve inc it's a multiplayer
competitive spy game where you get to
use social stealth high-tech gadgets and
powerful spy abilities to try and get
the upper end we've had the chance of
working with tripwire presents on the
project so this is only the beginning
please follow us on social media at play
this evening to learn more we'll be
releasing the game in early 2023 on pc
xbox series s nx and ps5 thank you so
much and let's enjoy the trailer
good afternoon agents your mission is
simple infiltrate the frozen coral
underwater hotel and retrieve the
blueprint of a powerful weapon as you
know deceiving's company policy is to
deploy multiple agents to ensure the
mission's success
but only one will get the paycheck do
whatever it takes agent and be careful
out there try your best let's see if
it's enough
oh come on they can't be this fast
[Music]
then they thought it was secure
in the end i am victorious
[Music]
they're really not going to make it easy
for me
gotcha
is that it
right on target
outskilled and outgoing
it
[Music]
target acquired moving to rendezvous
point
all done
really
mission complete
[Music]
let me ask you something do you ever
have a recurring dream that you really
wish would come true i mean mine
personally involves a flight of unicorns
and a valkyrie army on pegasuses but you
know yours may be different but you know
somehow i doubt it this year we've
partnered with the pc builders at i buy
power to bring a very different dream to
life my dream pc room
unfortunately there's bad news for me i
don't get to keep it but very good news
for one of you we're going to be giving
the entire contents of this room away to
a lucky winner watching the show so
let's dive in and see what's up for
grabs
the beating heart of any pc gaming dream
room is of course the rig so let's start
there as you can see the mad geniuses
that i buy power have built an absolute
doozy the first thing you'll notice is
that height y60 case with its wraparound
tempered glass panels this thing is
built from the ground up to display the
sickest pc tech you can squeeze into a
desktop machine and let's face it if
you've managed to bag a serious graphics
card in these dry dry times you owe it
to the silicon gods to show it off
properly okay the case and lighting
looks dope but for this to be a true
dream pc we need more than just state of
the art drip luckily the substance
matches the style so let's check out the
guts of our dream pc and trust me
there's plenty of power crammed in the
big question though is what pixel pusher
i buy power has used and you won't be
disappointed with an overclocked rtx
3090 from gigabyte right this 24
gigabyte monster of a gpu packs the
cooling to stay chill and the power to
smash through any game you throw at it
the graphics card is the riggs mvp but
any superstar needs some dope backup and
the fastest gaming cpu around the intel
5.5 gigahertz core i9 12 900 ks with 32
gigabytes of ddr5 ram and 2 terabytes of
seriously fast ssd storage both from
adata makes up the perfect support team
that is a whole lot of pc
but mika you may greedily wonder what
about the peripherals well animal lovers
we got you covered because the height
eclipse wireless headset comes in plush
vegan leather trim with a 30 hour
battery life and competition grade 2.4
gigahertz connection and you noisy
typers are going to love the clicky
clacky mechanical keyboard that comes
with it
oh i'm sorry what was that
rgb well of course the keyboard and
mouse both light up like atlantic city
on a saturday night and yeah you can
turn it off so you can actually get some
sleep you can find out more about this
gear feature today over at ibuypower.com
but i know what you really want to know
the info on how to win this beastly
setup so here are the details
thanks mika yes folks it couldn't be
easier to enter our dream pc giveaway
for your chance just head over to
pcgamer.com
dreampc and follow the simple
instructions there you'll find a
complete breakdown of the prize which
don't worry also comes with some very
swish monitors as well as the
eligibility rules good luck gamers
that is right just head over to
pcgamer.com
dream pc for your chance to win but for
now let's get back to the games from
kepler interactive and a4 games comes
flintlock the siege of dawn an action
rpg from the team behind ashen where
gods and guns collide
when the gods first emerged from the
great below
we saw them as saviors
instead they unleashed a pestilence on
our world
no one yet knows if you can kill a god
i for one
intend to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
hey pc gaming show i'm derek bradley the
ceo of a4 games and creative director of
flintlock the siege of dawn
flintlock is set in a world ruled by old
gods and so as humanity you now have the
power of black powder and bombs and
flintlock rifles to finally overthrow
the gods and take the world back you'll
play as nor a black stream sapper one of
the elite explosives experts of the
coalition forces
noor herself has a personal vendetta
against the gods and will stop at
nothing to get her revenge but she won't
be going it alone when all brings
firepower her foxlight companion inky
brings magic to the battlefield you will
have to master a combination of axe
combat and gunplay while your companion
enki uses his magical powers to disrupt
enemies we can't wait to show you more
of flintlock before it's released next
year head over to our socials for more
info and don't forget to wishlist now on
steam and epic game store have a great
show
coming up next a mysterious new sci-fi
game from 11 bit studios the creators of
this war of mine hear all about it in
our exclusive interview
we'll also show you what's next for
outriders from square enix and people
can fly
plus if you look back on high school and
think you know those four years would
have been better if i was fighting
literal demons you're definitely going
to want to study up on our next world
exclusive independent game inspired by
the persona series
choke your health potions now because
there is so much more pc gaming show
coming your way before we go the folks
at compass data centers have a little
quiz for you
how much higher is 5g data capacity
compared to current 4g networks
scan this qr code and answer the
question for a chance to win 500 bucks
worth of stuff from razer or visit
gaming.com
okay now back to the pc gaming show
ready to game the system
meet manor you slay you achieve
you win so should your bank account
because your power shouldn't stop when
the game does
mana is the best gaming rewards debit
card where you can earn perks and points
by paying and playing and get rewarded
with the things you actually want like
that skin you can't wait to show off or
your next gear upgrade so why pay any
other way pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
so i know what you're thinking and the
answer is yes it's time to talk about
the altars the brand new game from 11
bit studios the warsaw base studio made
us cry in this war of mine make
difficult choices in the face of climate
apocalypse in frost punk and battle
encroaching corruption and children of
morta the altar sends us to the deepest
darkest reaches of space in a survival
story that is guaranteed to give you an
existential crisis in a good way this is
a really big moment for this year's show
i can't wait let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
joining us now to talk about what we
just saw all the way from poland is
thomas casilevich of 11 bit studios
welcome to the pc gaming show and thanks
so much for joining us thank you so much
hello okay there is a lot to unpack
there we got clones we got this huge
wheel tell us what did we just see well
first of all these guys were not exactly
the clones
we saw jan our main character who's
traveling with a group of the altars who
are the alternative versions of the same
person
and they are going through this distant
alien planet
in their mobile base which was the wheel
you saw at the end so what's the
player's goal as they're progressing
through the story so you are a space
builder stranded on this distant planet
and your goal is to survive and find a
way back home
but the thing is in order to do so you
need to create those altars as each one
of them have different set of skills and
character traits
so
these are things necessary for your
survival and finding a way back home
so from the trailer tonally this could
be a horror thriller a mystery what
should players expect
actually there are bits of everything
you mentioned like there is this mystery
as we're looking deep into the soul of
the character but what you find there
can also be pretty scary so there are
those bits of psychological horror and
drama but then on top of it we have this
quite thick layer of surreality i mean
how surreal would it be to one day you
know wake up next to a little different
alternative version of your very self
now there's a quote that you shared with
me earlier that man cannot remake
himself without suffering for he is both
the marble and the sculptor how does
this quote relate to the story
so this quality
relates directly to the main theme of
our game we as people we are shaping
ourselves every single day with every
single decision that we are making this
process the whole process of becoming
who we are it can be quite painful at
times but in our game
jan the main character he has this
unique possibility of not only shaping
himself but also reshaping himself and
numerous times with every single alter
that he is creating do you see this is
more of a classic sci-fi story something
like a ray bradbury work or is it
something more contemporary
well it is very classic sci-fi in a way
that
we are taking a relatable topic
and we are using the sci-fi
theme we are using the sci-fi setting to
look at it through like through the
magnifying lenses but then when we're
choosing the tools this is a very
contemporary game and we're taking
advantage of what video games are as a
medium so we're using tools like
systematic design and non-linearity in
order to put the players in the middle
of the experience and in the end allow
them to create their own stories inside
the game i wanted to ask a little bit
about the relationship of your previous
titles to the altars whether there's any
narrative or themes or even just
influence that those games had on this
one well the altars is purely a hundred
percent our game 11-bit studios game and
it's
created in line with our meaningful
entertainment philosophy so it's a game
we hope that it will make you think even
after you stop playing it this war of
mine was this first huge milestone it it
paved the way for all the future titles
and with frostpunk it was taken to
another level with the strong focus on
the emergent narrative and now with the
alters we want to follow that path but
we also really want to push the
boundaries even further and expand on
how we approach meaningful topics
inside the design of our games
thanks so much again to tomash and the
whole team at 11 bit studios for joining
us this year and while i try to find
enough rapidium to make it through day
one to eight let's head on over to mika
burton and keep things rolling like a
massive space station
thanks day nine honestly i need to look
into getting myself cloned so i can make
time to play all these awesome games
we've seen so far
but i'm also like legitimately worried
about having to eventually fight my
clone in single hand to hand combat when
they steal my life making me wonder if i
was the clone all along
is it really worth it
video game yeah i know it's totally
worth it for video games anyway that's a
problem for future mika present mika is
much more interested in what you all
have been saying about the show so far
so keep letting us know your thoughts by
using
pc gaming show on all platforms now
let's get back to the real reason i'll
hear cloning i mean video games
video games
one two three
[Applause]
one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
sure sure when tiny build lets you open
your own medieval potion shop you get
hailed as a master alchemist but when i
do it i get a sternly word letter from
my landlord about my cauldron violates
our lease agreement whatever it's his
loss but more importantly folks we
promise you the maximum amount of games
humanly possible and we aim to deliver
quite literally
[Music]
wow
[Music]
go
the questions how bad
[Music]
twice
[Music]
before your eyes lies the celestial
islands
a world of peace above the clouds
protected by four great houses
[Music]
baby
[Music]
planet earth our beautiful home to
protect it we must reach out to explore
the unknown
our team of experts presently probing
the deep sea in a struggle against the
yoke of over-regulation
these security and defense innovations
allow you to shrink any problem down to
size
we surge forward obliterating the
enemies of progress but we refuse to let
these victories go to our heads
we are the future we are
orzin
and now it's time to give you an
exclusive briefing on what's next for
one of pc gaming's titans of modding
simulation and scale arma 4.
last month developer bohemia interactive
kicked things off by releasing arma
reforger on steam in early access this
playable prototype will be a foundation
for arma 4. and with it playable on
steam now we have a ton of questions
about the future of arma i mean after
all this is the series that helped birth
the survival genre through daisy oh and
also this other little niche genre you
may have heard of called battle royale
to help us peer into the future for this
project we've got none other than
bohemia interactive thank you so much
for joining us so as of right now armor
of forger has been out for about a month
what is it that you've been learning or
seeing from players
at first we've learned that players
like reforge a lot and they appreciate
the work we've put into it we also
realize they like modding a lot and they
reviewed
this as a
key quality of our games
and uh
we are very pleased by the reactions of
both our community and the new players
who immediately started flooding
internet with videos playthroughs and
praise of
our new technology so we are very glad
that the reception was so good so
there's no doubt players who have been
long time fans of the franchise stepping
into armor of forger and i'm curious
what were some of the big challenges of
rebuilding that specific arm of feel
from the ground up in this brand new
engine
well it's a very tricky subject because
even internally it's an ongoing kind of
fight
so i i'm myself
very much on the very purist side of
things so no hard no safe games no
superficial helpers and this fight can
get very intense even in house so i'm
the real armapurist and i'm on this for
25 years now so i will keep fighting but
obviously this is part of the fun so
this always never-ending battle i think
two years ago we really struggled to
keep it keep it arma and even internally
preserve our own standards so do it our
own way rather than replicating what's
maybe normal in other games because our
goal is not to make the same game as all
other games so our goal is to remain
unique i'm curious if you can speak to
what the main goals of reforger is
because it's a little unusual compared
to other releases i mean for instance
how much content should a player expect
if say they've been playing arma 3 for
years
our goals were of course to restart the
series uh from technological standpoint
really
make room for uh some new achievements
uh
utilize the technology which is
state-of-the-art both in terms of how it
looks like how it's controlled how it
can be modded it's important to
understand uh it may look as a kind of
normal game on the surface but there's a
big system behind it so just the tool
suite is a massive tool suite never
tested by a large public so it's a
premiere of a tool suite and these tools
are being built for nearly five years
now so we really need users to start
using them to keep improving and
continue building it
sorry to interrupt but we have one quick
question from the armor fans has
russia's invasion of ukraine impacted
your approach to arma 4 and armor of
forger a game that depicts the cold war
well yes because it's extremely close to
us we even live
in
a way very nearby so definitely
on the other hand we started work on
this many years ago so the direction was
set uh before but we always approach
conflicts and armed conflicts with the
great level of respect we're still at
the beginning but we definitely would
like to continue in our exploring this
serious team arma as i see it has always
been a bit more of a anti-war game it's
an entertainment product that's fair uh
fair thing to admit
on the other hand uh given the topic
given
our let's say
maturity and long time we've spent on it
and our ambition to
portray it uh as a whole very complex
and gritty thing i would like us to
contribute by not just entertaining
people but also educating them on the
subject this was the wall point of
starting the cooperation with the
international committee of the red cross
and i believe we have great potential
big responsibility in this era and a
very important chance to contribute at
least a little bit to
the good side of things
this would not be an interview about
arma unless we were asking about modding
i mean so many amazing games and genres
came from arma mods so i gotta know
what's possible in reforger that wasn't
possible in the past now with this
technology is possible to create
entirely different things like entirely
different games it has so many variables
but the beauty now is that much more of
it is user accessible unlike the
previous games so people can easily
digest how this is constructed in our
workbench tools so
unlike previously where it was more hard
coded in the c plus engine so now they
can check the data of every single
element of the game and go much much
deeper than in previous games so this
will be super exciting now i wanted to
ask a little bit about performance
because anyone who's played arma knows
that it can get really challenging to
get a good frame rate in those massive
multiplayer matches so i'm curious what
expectation should players have about
performance leading into arma 4. arma 3
was built on foundations laid down in
times of single core and no gpus
basically so this time much more
computations and
intensive
rendering things can be done directly on
gpu but it requires completely a new
approach again we are in the beginning
and we we know that there are problems
there are difficulties where we are
solving them one by one we are really
gathering community feedback and even
our own definitely feedback so we are
moving things forward and uh yeah it's
about optimization it's not
not that much about fps but also like
network traffic for instance then you
have this
muscle multiplayer game it's a it's a
huge challenge server performance of
course and
all the technical things so we are we're
moving forward
thank you so much again bohemia
interactive for giving us the inside
scoop on both armor of forger and arma
4. now you don't go anywhere because
here is what's around the corner
just around the corner in the pc gaming
show prepare to experience terror
ranging from the subaqueous to the
subconscious with the latest from
shearer games hold on to your butts
because fronted development spared no
expense on the new jurassic world
evolution 2 expansion and get your
crowbars ready for half-life alex
levitation a special project from some
very talented modders oh modders what
would pc gaming be without you while
we're here quick geography question
which parts of the world use the most
bandwidth for gaming answer this
question for the folks at compass data
centers and it could win you a 500 razer
gift card scan the qr code on the screen
to enter
last year shiro games debuted war tales
at the pc gaming show but the publisher
has a lot more than its medieval sandbox
rpg on the way up next we'll hear what's
up with shiro's slated projects and
stick around for the debut of two
completely new games decarnation and
abyssals
hey everyone thank you very much for the
invitation mika i'm james and i can't
wait to show you everything we've got
prepared for you today so it's been a
crazy couple of months for everyone here
at shiro games with dune spice wars
marking the most successful release in
the history of the company and it's
entirely thanks to all of you
but today let's look at doom spice wars
multiplayer mode up to four players can
go head to head in free for all 2v2 all
work together and co-op against ai
opponents
we're introducing new synergy systems
between factions that will open a vast
number of strategies to help you crush
your opponents
multiplayer will be available in doom
spice wars very soon
after five years and nearly three
million units sold northgard's story
finally continues
in a new chapter set shortly after the
events of the first campaign ragnarok
has decimated the lands of northgard
long-standing alliances have been broken
violence and betrayal now plagued the
continent
forced to depart what they once called
home
our heroes arrive on unknown shores and
find themselves confronted by unfamiliar
faces in a dangerous new realm
this north guard expansion arrives this
winter
[Music]
and for all of our tales players out
there cooperative is finally coming to
our open world tactical rpg
you share food gold and camp with your
friends
but you can split up to cover more
grounds
before every fight devise the perfect
strategy to overcome any threats that
may stand in your way
but be careful when your approach as one
wrong move may lead to your group's
demise
the co-op update will allow you to play
between two to four players and it will
be available this summer
so a few months ago we announced shiro
unlimited a new publishing label created
by indies for indies and we are very
proud to announce two new titles coming
from the shiro unlimited family
[Music]
it seemed like our last chance to start
again
to escape earth's devastation
we used our limited resources to lay the
foundations of a new life
deep below the waves of this strange new
planet
but soon
we realized it was not the dream world
we had hoped for
when faced against the darkness of the
abyss
we found ourselves helpless
last
isolated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much for sticking with us
everyone we hope you enjoy the rest of
the show
you just saw why you were exactly right
to be afraid of the ocean in abyssals
and you confronted your inner demons in
the retro dream horror of decarnation
next up how do you rebuild a city in a
world set after the collapse of
civilization let's find out how by
taking a look at i am future from
tinybuild
[Music]
top
warning
hibernation aborted
your total hibernation time was
six years six months five days
welcome to eden your new home
[Music]
i have no idea where the hell i am
but damn this place is gorgeous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
our forefathers conquered cult area
and bestowed it upon us a new generation
to share
or spar over
[Music]
our great house is sick to obtain the
emperor's favor cultivating our lands
and subjects to improve and enrich the
realm
beginning with ourselves of course
prominence can be secured through
strength
as well as delicacy
[Music]
will you be able to build your legacy of
power
join
the great houses of calgaria
and now for these next trailers
it's true
they do move in herds
that was so much the thought process is
simple god creates dinosaurs god
destroys dinosaurs man destroys god man
creates video games to play with
dinosaurs but just be warned that one of
these trailers might come as a bit of a
shock to the system
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the very notion to disgusts me
look upon my works foul creatures and
weep at its magnificence
it is a beautiful day on citadel station
look at you hacker
a pathetic creature of meat and bone how
can you challenge a perfect
immortal machine
you are an insect you are
nothing
i create
i
iterate
i fuse flesh and steel into perfection
[Music]
their blood is on your hands
you will suffer for your transgressions
transgressions
these are my other adventures
and they will have retribution
[Music]
what an incredible and frankly
horrifying trailer developed by night
dive studio system shock is the return
of a beloved acclaimed sci-fi saga today
to take us even further inside the world
of system shock i am thrilled to welcome
the one and only war inspector thanks so
much for joining us warren hey thanks
for having me this is going to be uh fun
in terms of trying to translate the
experience of a game from 1994 three
decades later to now what doesn't carry
over well the first thing is the
graphics obviously
we did the best we could
uh but uh it was pretty primitive back
then
and the the other one is the user
interface if you look at the when the
game opened uh the original a help
screen that came up and it filled the
entire screen with text
it's just a thing
i don't know now the guys at night that
did it it's amazing but
frankly as i think back on it the game
actually holds up pretty well i'm
excited to see it come back just
wondering if you think many modern
gamers are aware of the impact that
system shock has had in terms of
gameplay systems in terms of narrative
structure on so many games that came
after it i'm not sure people see the
influence which is uh a little a little
unfortunate but i think the rest of the
world is is going to get the chance now
to experience it and i i think they'll
see not just that they're having fun
playing this game but also see that
other games followed in his footsteps
nowadays we walk around with computers
in our pockets we're worried about the
evil of algorithms how do you think
about a character like shodan in 2022
showdown seems
far too close to reality to me right now
and let's just hope that she doesn't
show up it's nasty a form as she did
back in 1994. well warren i want to
thank you so much for joining us i want
to let you know i cannot wait to return
back to that world i played and enjoyed
so much as a kid cheers i can't wait to
return to that world
i forgot basically
fans know way more about the game than i
do now so it'll be a new experience for
me too thank you so much again warren
spector for joining us to talk all
things system shock i personally can't
wait for the game to come out though it
might completely ruin my sleep schedule
but before i spiral further here are
some more games to cram into your
eyeballs
since the first
pioneers the harshest aspects of our
world every generation has upheld the
solemn promise of our daughters
that the rise of titan would forever be
without misery or bludgeon
we seek nothing from the solar system
but a lasting amity of reason and
justice
to see a war under any pretext would
bring ruin to the great wellness of
mankind
any victory achieved through that
deepest expression of human honor
would be as devastating as defeat
we have but a singular balance to
establish peace and security for all
mankind
the war between mars and tides and
devastated our solar system lead the
survivors to damarat where you will
continue falling frontier's storyline
campaign in orbit of an alien star
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right gamers good work you've made
it here to a site of grace or a bonfire
or a sculptor's idol or a lamp make sure
you're staying hydrated replenish your
potions and most importantly keep
letting us know what games you're
excited about using
pc gaming show i mean personally i can't
wait to play the altars oh good now
we're all rested up feeling good it's
time to enjoy a slice of that lovely
cyberpunk life courtesy of novalis and
experience the investigative horror of
immortality the latest from the mind of
sam barlow
[Music]
i believe we have a short clip here do
you want to tell us what we're about to
see well i don't want to spoil things
too much
[Music]
does this work as confession
[Music]
[Music]
did you ever be this diary
[Music]
we can take a break
you should take a break
[Music]
hey boss time to wake up we got
customers waiting
what do you mean you don't know where to
start let's clean this place up move
some chairs and tables around we can
make this place shine again
if the weather gets bad we can grow some
veg in the greenhouse
once we start making real money well
then you can rent that fancy new
apartment in midtown
[Music]
so make friends make enemies if
customers are rude just turn on the old
charm or water down their drinks i'm not
your conscience
this is a world to explore
to make stories
your stories
you ever look up at the clouds and
wonder what's up there well if you dream
big enough maybe you'll find out maybe
we all will
welcome to nivalis
[Music]
hi i'm marco and i'm roman at islands we
are big fans of cyberpunk fiction and
games but we have our own ideas of what
a cyberpunk world can be this is the
game in which you manage your restaurant
bar or nightclub take care of your staff
make deals car and experience the
stories of the people you meet or maybe
you just want to take the day off and go
fishing at the docks instead niwalis
primarily uses voxol art for the
environments we spend lots of time
creating a unique atmosphere with high
levels of detail and dynamic elements
we are excited about the cyberpunk world
we making and we can't wait to see the
choices you'll make and how you'll
choose to live your life when you come
visit us in diwali
you can wishlist niwalas now on steam
and the epic game store
mana is the gaming rewards debit card
that puts the power back in the hands of
players so with every quest you complete
and every purchase you make you're
earning for the rewards you actually won
we make it easy for you to set up and
start just sync your favorite games to
your mana account and start earning real
life rewards the next time you play
so why pay any other way
pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
get ready to overclock your eyeballs
because this next trailer is coming in
hotter than my computer with three
chrome tabs open
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you just saw demon school from welsh
developer isbridge games and now it's
time to take a bit of a spooky
transition if you're at home turn on all
the lights in the room make sure the
salt circle is unbroken and check to see
that your door is properly painted with
sacrificial lamb's blood because things
are about to get certifiably terrifying
let's look at the h.r giger inspired
biopunk horror scorn
desolate
and
decayed
a grisly nightmare of macabre perception
greetings
i'm your host
doug bradley
and i invite you to join me as we
explore scorn's mesmerizing labyrinth of
art forms
and somber tapestries
you
awake the middle of a desolate hellscape
filled with biomechanical contraptions
part flesh
part machine
an industrial civilization now lying in
decay and ruin
a hidden foreigner sleeps within the
underbelly of the world
wanting nothing more than to be left
undisturbed
scorn has been carefully crafted with
great attention to detail everything is
focused on building a specific
atmosphere
from a unique organic ecosystem to an
unsettling soundscape created by ethec
and lust moored
scorn has no dialogue so most of the
storytelling comes from the environment
discovering the ever-present symbiotic
relationships and how things are
connected equips you with the tools to
progress
while there is shooting within the game
scorn is not a shooter
every encounter must be carefully
considered a wrong choice could be
deadly
i hope you've enjoyed this glimpse into
the twisted world of scorn
the team at ab software can't wait for
you to uncover the secrets of this
unique world as you experience scorn
first hand this october
are you prepared to unravel your inner
self
within scorn's world
of horror
[Music]
now while i've been delightedly playing
dune spice wars harvesting melange and
trying to figure out how to pronounce
quest croissants how to wrap it doesn't
matter i'm equally ready to turn hordes
of tyranids into a jackson pollock
painting in warhammer 40k space marine
2. in this brutal third-person shooter
you once again step into the oversized
power armor of titus an elite primary
space marine in a galaxy immersed in a
never-ending war to take us further
inside the grim dark i am joined by tim
willits and oliver hollis the creative
director on warhammer 40k space marine
2. first of all thank you so much for
joining us
yes thank you thanks for having us good
to be here now tim i want to start with
you you previously worked at id software
on doom how would you say the space
marine compares to doom guy
that is a good question uh i bet many
people did not know that the original
doom guy was actually a space marine
inspired by
an even older space marine which is the
warhammer 40 000 space marine so you
know it's really exciting for for me to
work on
space marine too you know because it's a
great franchise and i know that it's
inspired so many other video games
throughout the last 25 30 years oh oh
absolutely and there's so much lore to
sift through and i think this brings us
to talk a little bit about the new space
marine that you're going to get to play
a primary space i mean oliver talk to us
a little bit about captain titus and
what makes this class of space marine
different from the others in the
universe so the space marine is a
brainchild of the emperor uh the kind of
leader of this uh of humanity in the
grim dark future he saw the dangers that
the universe presented and he created a
super soldier from his own dna and each
of these different factions the
different chapters have different
genetic traits of the emperor but what
makes the primaris different is that a
guy named belisarius call the emperor's
kind of chief scientist went back did
some digging in the old uh data and
found a way to enhance the the qualities
that a space marine has by installing
new devices new kind of bio implants in
their body so now these guys are two and
a half meter tall monsters capable of
destroying anything in their path it's
reminding me of the thousand times i
have re-watched the astartes animation
it's amazing so exciting it's so
exciting that we now get to be in that
position to play that kind of character
and in the trailer we saw a lot of
tyranids are they the main enemy that
you're going to be against if so what
makes them such a compelling foe in this
particular game the tyranids are the
main focus and what makes them
compelling is that they are extra
galactic
locust like creatures they've come in
from goodness knows where they spread
like wildfire they devour everything in
their path and they leave nothing in
their wake so one of the great things
about the tyranids is they come in the
thousands
and our proprietary engine the saber
swarm engine can can deliver these epic
battles now we will have thousands of
tyranids and you will rip and tear
through them all i mean that is so
thrilling because this is the sort of
thing that older games couldn't even
hope to do and you're talking a little
bit about combat i know that some of the
previous entries were more melee focused
what's the combat like in space marine 2
so the combat in space marine 2 is a mix
of your face melee combat along with
some really cool over-the-top weapons so
um you know we
we we looked at you know the original
space marine game where they where it
had a lot of this push forward combat
which has inspired many other video
games but uh but that never stop never
take cover combat is integral to space
marine 2 along with you know these these
really cool powerful weapons so you're
either tearing up the enemies in front
of you or you're blowing them away from
the back of the battlefield it's uh it's
it's the best of both worlds i mean that
sounds so terrific and i mean i know you
guys are huge fans of the 40k lore so
i'm curious about in working on this
project what's been the most fun seeing
come together and let's say we're
interacting focusing on right now right
at the beginning of the project tim and
i went to the warhammer museum which was
an incredible experience and you go
around all these cabinets where these
incredible miniatures that have been
painted by these masters are arranged in
these dioramas you find yourself kind of
crouching down and looking into the
ranks of space marines that are facing
tyranids or orcs or whatever and
something that tim and i said at that
moment was we need to make this come
alive i don't want to look at this i
want to be inside this i want to be
gunning down tyranids by the thousands
and so
seeing that actually happen and come
alive has been thrilling am i going to
feel like the characters in the astartes
animation because if so then i'm buying
the game immediately
even more so when you're wielding one of
those massive weapons and you're faced
with a thousand tyranids all want to eat
you alive and you're just letting rip
and you can see shell casings bursting
out of these massive weapons one after
another
the sound the gameplay the way it feels
is all designed to make you feel like
the most powerful warrior in the
universe well perfect that answers
everything thank you so much tim and
oliver from saber interactive for
joining us i can't wait warhammer 40k
space marine 2 comes to pc ps5 xbox
series x and s soon now next we have a
few more surprises for you up the
sleeves of our proverbial power armor
first replicant d6's homage to the
golden days or should i say golden eyes
of 90s console shooters and an
atmospheric sci-fi adventure on the red
planet from frontier developments and
kyoken interactive let's take a look
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
sarah
ryan
this is kathy
can you hear me
please come in
mission opera has only one objective
bring the arks and their revolutionary
technology back home
here we go oprah team
the journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step
i need to know
that when we get there
[Music]
you'll make the right decisions
we can do this
what do you expect to find on mars
hi my name's elise chapel and i play
cathy johansson in the out of this world
sci-fi epic deliverous mars
join kathy and the crew of the zephyr on
an unmissable adventure as they journey
to the red planet to recover technology
vital to the survival of earth and
humankind
deliver deliverous mars is set to land
on september 27th and is available to
pre-order now on playstation xbox steam
and the epic game store
stay a while
and listen
to this list of games still to come the
team behind half-life alex levitation
will put their mod where their mouth is
and then it's paradox time not as in us
creating an actual time paradox we're
going to show you the latest from
victoria 3
plus you can literally scare your entire
butt off with the creeping horror of
gloomwood all this and more in just a
moment but first a final pop quiz for
all you valorant cs go and league of
legends players how much has esports
revenue increased since 2016. compass
data centers wants to hear your guess
and you can scan this qr code on the
screen for a chance to win a 500 razer
gift card
visit
gaming.compassdatacenters.com to enter
all right and now
back to the show
up next we're going to take a look at
stormgate the highly anticipated
real-time strategy game from frost giant
then our resident rts addict is going to
sit down with some of the game
developers to ask the hard-hitting
questions like when can we play this
already
two years ago our team assembled with a
shared vision to build a brand new
real-time strategy game together we've
been fortunate to work on some of the
greatest rts games of all time and now
we have a chance to do it again by
creating the next evolution of that
legacy today we are so excited to share
a first glimpse of stormgate an
exclusive sneak peek into the universe
and game that we've been creating for
you
stormgate takes place in an all-new
post-apocalyptic setting where science
fiction and fantasy collide
our story begins hundreds of years in
earth's future following the near
extinction of humanity
this great calamity was caused by the
infernal host a playable alien race of
demonic invaders that are hell-bent on
claiming this planet as their own
with our story we are creating an
ever-expanding game universe told
through an ongoing series of campaign
missions that you can play solo or
cooperatively
new chapters will come out regularly
along with new units maps modes and
plenty of other surprises
in addition to campaign missions we're
building a world-class competitive
experience with grassroots and
professional tournaments accessible from
directly within the game
there will be different leagues suitable
for all levels of experience
in our new three-player co-op versus ai
mode you'll level up your heroes collect
rewards and customize your forces to
open up new styles of gameplay and
long-term variety
stormgate will be free to play but not
pay to win and there will be no nfts
beta testing starts next year and you
can sign up now to reserve your place in
line at playstormgate.com
you might happen to know that i'm a huge
fan of real-time strategy games
starcraft is my favorite game i've
played it for 25 years i still play it
and that's why i am so thrilled today to
be talking to frost giant studios
they're a group of amazing developers
who have worked on literally my favorite
games of all time and we're here to talk
about their brand new free-to-play
real-time strategy game set in a
post-apocalyptic earth it's stormgate
and here to talk about it is the ceo and
production director at frost giant tim
morton thanks for joining us tim thank
you so much for having me here i want to
know about the world i want to know
about the game tell us what is stormgate
alright this is our first game as a new
studio
and
it is classic real-time strategy but
designed to be
more social we build the game in a
universe that ties everything together
but provide different kinds of
experiences for players who like
different kinds of gameplays so we've
got
cooperative campaign mode also play
open-ended co-op but if you're somebody
who really enjoys competition we've got
one versus one high skill competitive
and those are very different ways to
play in some ways but they're also all
unified by the universe by the races by
the units so you really
get a sense for how to enjoy the game
and i'm curious a little bit about that
core gameplay because obviously in all
these modes you're going to be
collecting money building bases building
units and so on and i know that for you
the game feeling really good and really
smooth to play is super important now
obviously i i come from a time where if
the pathfinding is bad we call that high
skill opportunity but i mean how do you
think about getting the controls the
motions just the feel of the game to
feel good in 2022 yeah it's interesting
that rts is one of the only genres i can
think of where you have to have hundreds
even thousands of units synchronized
over the network and responsive in a way
that high skill like pro esports players
feel good about playing the game that's
not easy it does require custom
technology um there's no engine that you
buy off the shelf that does that for you
so we definitely started
knowing that
and having the benefit of our chief
architect james andhold who did that
work
previously on starcraft 2. um so we've
put a lot of effort into that for sure
and this is going to be one of the first
major rts's people are aware of that is
on unreal engine 5. what is it like
working in this next generation engine
it's pretty incredible how far things
have come from a graphics perspective
and i think the art team is unlocked in
so many ways by what unreal provides so
we're very excited we're still learning
everything that unreal can do for us but
even that first cinematic that we
debuted like that's done and unreal so
the high quality graphics that you're
seeing are actually coming from unreal
as an engine so you've talked a little
bit about for new players making the
game feel a little more approachable a
little bit more streamlined but
obviously starcraft real time strategy
has this astonishingly long history as a
competitive game as an esport and i'm
curious how is your team going to
approach that so a lot of the emphasis
around our thinking has been focused on
what are things that we can add
especially around the gameplay
experience one of those things is
more seamless integration with esports i
mean being able to sign up participate
in tournaments directly from the client
in a way that gives players even if
you're not like top grand master yeah
ready to take on cyril there's still an
opportunity to be the best on your block
or the best at your company or the best
at your schools so we want to facilitate
esports all the way from grassroots
level up to the pro level directly in
the client so of course in the history
of rts games a really important
component of them has always been mods i
mean warcraft 3 there's players that
didn't even play the original game they
just did custom mode after custom mode
does stormgate have modding how are you
thinking about the modding community a
number of members of the frost giant
team actually came out of the modding
community the team as a whole is very
passionate about it from the outset we
started out applying resources to build
a custom editor
i think there's a lot of opportunity to
make improvements to the editing
experience for rts we are also working
on the infrastructure for people to be
able to share their mods with each other
so it's really core to us as a team to
enable modding and we're absolutely
working on it and of course we have to
end with my favorite question of all
when can we play the game and how do we
play it tim so we are gonna start our
beta in 2023 we already have a site
stood up at playstormgate.com to be able
to register for the beta we have a lot
of active discussion topics on our
subreddit as well so there's an
opportunity to participate in the
dialogue around what we're building tim
thank you so much for joining us again
today we just got a chance to talk about
stormgate the upcoming free to play rts
from frost giant studios i'm personally
super pumped to play it and be sure to
check it out at playstormgate.com now
tim i'm going to do with transition to
the next game are you ready it's going
to be good watch this is going to be so
sick next we're going to show you lasara
summit kingdom from quite okay games now
as someone who has spent a medically and
advisable amount of time playing
strategy games of all sorts this looks
incredibly up my alley and it looks a
lot safer than my last attempt to create
society in the mountains two words to
yodeling accident let's check it out
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was frozen flame an open world
survival rpg from dreamside interactive
where you'll embark on a fantasy
adventure in a world reshaped by a
magical calamity a cursed land full of
environmental hazards and massive
monsters doesn't sound like the kind of
place you'd want to build a cozy home
with your friends but instead you'll be
raising fortresses and trying to tame
the world eventually growing tough
enough to tackle the citadel that looms
over everything and break the curse or
you'll end up in the belly of a monster
eh still kind of cozy the demo for
frozen flame was released just before
the show so you can jump in or grab some
co-op buddies and see how long you can
survive for right now and keep an eye
out for the early access launch later
this year
[Music]
if you could listen to the noise of
history
then you would hear by the sounds of the
victorian age
that the world changed forever
the roar of the engines the bangs from
new factories and the cries in the
streets
calling out for revolution
in victoria 3 we simulate this era 100
years starting in
1836
and put you in charge of a young society
[Music]
you will meet the people back then
high and low over cultures across the
globe
they are the beating hearts of your
nation and form powerful groups with
needs and desires
listen to their calls and let it
influence reform
or turn a deaf ear
to protect what is proven and stable
your politics will decide where you want
to go
but your economy
how far you've come
taxes production trade and construction
play these cards right and you can
harness the industrial revolution
to turn your cities into titans
this is the engine you will need on the
global stage use packs threats and
bluffs
to secure your place in the sun
anything done by war can be achieved
with diplomacy
but you can decide when push
comes to shove
here you
write the stories and over time the
history of your world
will be carved into the map
what will your society be like
what is the sound that will echo over
continents and be heard over the noise
of time
as you create
your grand
tomorrow
[Music]
that was the gameplay debut of victoria
3 from paradox interactive a grand
strategy game coming later this year
and let us take this moment to let you
know you can wish us victoria 3 by
visiting the pc gaming show event page
on steam where you'll be able to find
every game featured in today's show
type pcgamer.com wishlist into your
browser to be taken straight there and
now on with the show
so
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
what's up pc gamers we're back again now
what you just saw was everything new
blood's got going on for 2022 a medieval
the black labyrinth ultra kill act 2
faith fallen aces and a brand new update
for dusk that's bringing all new hd
models and weapons that nobody asked for
so we're doing it anyway now last year
you might have noticed we teased a bunch
of games here that we weren't ready to
talk about just yet and we're still not
ready to talk about those games but i
want to let you know that yes we're
still working on a top-down shooter yes
we're still working on a fallout style
rpg my dream game and yes we're still
working on a car combat game but we're
not ready to talk about those games just
yet what i want to talk about
is gloomwood now two years ago y'all
straight up forgot to show the gloomwood
trailer last year you bumped me so gabe
newell could talk about a bunch of demos
or some [ __ ] this year pc gamer you
promised you promised we would get the
show gloomwood so i don't want to hear
any [ __ ] if you're on a steam deck
ad right now or something
steam deck
powerful portable pc gaming pcgamer you
see this puppy
i will drown this puppy
i will if you don't let us show gloom
what i am going to drown this adorable i
would never i would never i would never
do that hi i love you so yeah
we good uh no can we show gloomwood
are you sure
well all right
it's about time
[Music]
hello
doctor
i had hoped for us to meet at my estate
no matter
i can guarantee your safe arrival
a promise few others here can make
the townsfolk are not fond of outsiders
don't delay
i'll be waiting
[Laughter]
there's only one thing i like more than
playing new bloods games and that's
probably the urls they make for them it
wouldn't be a pc gaming show without the
silliest most ridiculous website names
in human history which is why i'm
delighted to share that next we have a
group of such games that run the gamut
from medieval mayhem to an adorable
animal fight club and our first rule
we absolutely plan to talk about it
[Music]
[Music]
corrupted what
why is it always doing this just when i
need to showcase the game
okay
have you tried turning it off and on
again yes i have
the update to system 10.1.1 will provide
a clean sorting of all your files and
ensure that situations like this won't
ever happen oh no no no nobody's
updating me that's the thing
nope
thank you but we'll pass
okay so i do have a backup of the
trailer while i go rummage into the bin
for it please welcome my personal
assistant that will do a great job at
pitching the game for you
[Music]
uh talk about how cool i am in the story
and how funny witty
you know just talk about me
found it
ah ladies and gentlemen the trailer
[Music]
okay who had the amazing idea to save
the trailer back up in 14.4 pixels do we
have any ants working for us
[Music]
the survival of thy noble family depends
on their ability
to rule the city
to fight
with valor
and to learn
oh if only it were that easy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know what you're up to fuzz ball
but back off
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
that was the latest dlc for court keeper
the sandbox survival sim from fireshine
games and pugstorm the sunken sea biome
update is available on june 15th for all
core keeper players now we have even
more twists and turns and trailers so
press enter to continue did you press it
i'm going to go ahead and super prepped
it no but seriously press it
life
can be harsh
everywhere but in the old world there
was no hope of it ever improving
[Music]
when our crops failed the ruling class
would still collect the same share
leaving our children to staff
and if we had any coin to our name the
taxman would appear demanding you for
the crown
the nobles hid behind the safety of
their walls and did nothing when raiders
pillaged the outskirts of the city
and so
some of us decided that it was time to
leave
that we'd rather take our chances in the
wilderness
seeking the promise of a new land
and starve to death in our homeland
the journey wasn't easy
we lost many along the way
this wild unsettled land
offers us the hope of a new start
as the masters
of our own destiny
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
what is below is destined to be
understood
our life depends on the worms of the
weather
our life is tied to this earth
the water we harvest the plants we grow
there we filter
any waste would be fatal to our survival
we must learn to live in harmony with
this world
for too long we have wandered without
purpose
from now on our city will be a source of
hope
[Music]
[Music]
to understand our world we must explore
it
we must find the tablets
the seeds of knowledge that bind all the
elements together
to build our survival to build our city
to live happily
[Music]
welcome to icarus prospector
the planet we almost lost
then found a reason to stay
[Music]
take it from me
this place
wants you dead
but
we've made progress
learn the lay of the land
how to use icarus to our advantage
[Music]
our friends at the uda are offering up a
slice a whole new terrain
if you learn
build and survive
maybe
just maybe
there's a future here
think you got what it takes
in the rich tapestry of the pc gaming
community
modders are one of the most inspiring
subcultures in fact some of the most
popular genres today started as pc
gaming mods right now modders sean fmp1
snelling and corey lado are making
something incredibly special in the form
of an ambitious mod for half-life alex
it's called levitation it's an original
four to five hour campaign that builds
on valve's original vr game half-life
alex with alex searching for a pair of
rebels gone rogue they've discovered a
strange floating building in sector x
and decided to investigate it against
orders obviously and now it's your turn
let's go back to the world of gordon
g-man and alex with this exclusive
gameplay footage
alex according to this old resistance
map there's a control room somewhere
outside the building you're in
sorry if that's vague the map was drawn
using somebody's blood
so
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
alex i'm detecting an incredibly large
energy signature up ahead
it's probably gordon freeman and not
anything bad at all
definitely uh definitely probably gordon
freeman
[Music]
okay so the plan is to get to that
control room and get going
oh boy
so
getting kind of crowded down here ross
[Music]
you've seen that
[Music]
[Music]
oh crap moving moving
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
nice
[Music]
steady
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
face off left
oh boy
well folks this
is the end
we've learned a lot today
about ourselves about computers
about genetically engineered space
marines and with so many games on the
way there has truly never been a better
time to be part of the pc gaming
community over the course of the last
two hours we saw games from developers
all over the world and we wanted to
thank everyone who tuned in to watch the
show all the developers who shared their
work with us and of course all of the
partners for their help bringing the pc
gaming show to life indeed remember to
tip your servers install your firmware
updates
and tell me if you know where to find a
390ti tell me immediately anywhere you
can find one let me know and of course
a warm thanks to you again for joining
us at this year's pc gaming show it's
something i look forward to every year
and we're thrilled that you joined us
again see you next time bye bye
bye
this is the official pc gaming show 2022
pre-show it's the live show before the
uh the pre-recorded show
go to the start make sure you're staying
hydrated replenish your potions
let's do it again this is the first time
but before i spiral further into my
concerns here's even more
all right one more time
you just saw demon school from welsh
developed wish developer
you want perfect watch this
chart so now they're all rested up let's
enjoy a slice that's cyberpunk life
experience the we skipped the whole line
we accidentally the whole line we have
come to the end of our show at long last
with so many i
saw my spit fly out and i hope i get you
man oh good
and also i ate a snicker so i want to
make sure there's no just chocolate in
my teeth
[Music]
is already chocolate in my mouth
the 5.5 gigahertz core i9 12 900 ks with
a 32 gigabyte of ddr
was doing so well
oh
god there were so many numbers all at
once game reveals to share with you
which would only mean one thing it's
countdown
[Music]
i have a there's a lacroix burp
it's very close to the surface
it's not a heart attack it's just a burp
all right i'm going to do the take
it's gonna happen maybe
i could do this i could do this i could
do this i could do this get ready to
overclock your eyeballs because this
next trailer is coming in hotter than my
computer with more than three chrome
tabs open if you're getting carried in
with a seat belt then strap in because
this next trailer goes from zero to a
hundred real quick and i just got off
the phone with my doctor and he was like
exclusive gameplay levels are critically
low and i want to fix that like
immediately
[Music]
i had no idea where we're going it's the
first time i'd seen any of those words
when i just kept pushing it
there was no break i just
i don't know why i'm this way
but that's that's what i decided to do
sticking to it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you